dylan what's up man
what is going on
what's good oh my gosh
from greece lightning
yeah down at uh down at austin texas at
uh at a mining conference so taking this
one outside all right let's get into
bitcoin obviously bitcoin went down a
lot uh start the year uh december and
january uh pretty big price drawdowns
but now bitcoin has come back it didn't
die didn't go to zero all the bears are
wrong they're stunned in disbelief uh
let's start with uh just price weighted
by hourly uh perps funding rate
obviously uh last week and week before
you were talking a lot about the funding
rates and kind of waiting for negative
funding what are you seeing now what's
this telling us yeah so i mean we got it
uh you know we talked about derivatives
a lot here um and and really we like
this graphic a lot to show kind of uh
the bearish or bullishness in the
derivative market so uh when there's
negative funding and essentially what
that means is that derivative bets you
have long paying shorts i'm sorry shorts
paying longs
uh when okay let me spit it out here uh
when this line is read what you have is
is longs are being paid by shorts so uh
when you see kind of a short squeeze in
bitcoin and bitcoin is going vertical
oftentimes what's happening is in
derivative markets you have uh shorts
that are being forced uh forced to
become buyers or they're actually being
liquidated margin called in the legacy
system that's what it's called
and so
you have kind of that organic spot price
but oftentimes when you see these
volatile moves uh at tops and at bottoms
oftentimes it's really the derivative
markets that's driving the price action
uh and there's these forced unwinds that
are happening so we we kept talking
about will talks about it a lot uh when
we're going to get a regime of like
negative funding what that means is that
you're getting times where your shorts
are paying long to enter a position
they're paying longs to sit in a
derivative long position and so we saw
that we saw that at the bottom and we
saw as price was going up funding was
staying negative so so what that means
was that that perpetual swap price was
under the spot market price so whether
it's on finance or ftx perpetual swap or
bitmex it was under say the price of
bitcoin on coinbase it was under a spot
bitcoin market price and so that you can
think of like i like this analogy a lot
when funding is negative when when you
see that positioning under the spot
price it's like a beach ball underwater
and so uh it wasn't as significant as
say march of 2020 or even the summer but
this kind of recent squeeze we've got
this you know we've almost gotten kind
of vertical to 44 000 or around there um
it's because of you know the derivative
bets that have started to really unwind
and so uh you know that's what happens
when when bears get uh too bearish at
the bottom
got it and so if we look at the supply
held by wales that seems to uh be
significantly changing and they just
seem to be gobbling up bitcoin right now
holding as much of it as they possibly
can
yeah so we have here we have uh
basically a 30-day percentage change of
whales and retail and so
with the blue pattern is the blue color
is when both of these cohorts are
accumulating and so you can kind of see
like you can think of whales as like the
smart money and maybe they're not so
smart just as much as they they really
can uh you know change the market
structure just with how much capital
they have um so when you see both retail
and whales accumulating uh it's usually
you know somewhat of a bottom or like
it's a pretty good time to buy and so
recently we see we saw retailers
continued to buy the entire drawdown
whales were actually distributing and
recently that flipped so both whales and
retail are big buyers here and we've
seen that over the last month or so and
so uh i think that's a trend that's
that's pretty good to see and we'll see
if it continues into the future
got it and so then if we move and we
look at actual uh retail entities and uh
the whales when you start to compare
these uh over like the 30 day uh percent
change to me
what is a little bit hard to understand
maybe you can kind of help clarify this
is it doesn't seem like there's been
that big of a uh kind of delta or
movement uh since maybe december or so
how do you uh look at this and then if
you look over kind of the last few years
what are you seeing here
yeah so i think uh maybe i think our
slides were mixed i i changed it uh so
right right now i'm looking at the
supply held by only whale entities um so
so we're seeing that that accumulation
happened um and and we saw that
distribution at the at the basically the
top of the bull market and into the
downturn and we saw that distribution
kind of flip uh from november as uh
as as that cpi print came in really hot
and powell said you know hey we are
wrong inflation's not not transitory uh
and you saw somewhat of the smart money
like the you know the big whales start
to distribute a little bit so that's
flipped in accumulation mode again um
and really like you know these these
30-day trends um it's interesting to
monitor but but the reality is uh for
the most part bitcoins always in an
accumulation mode for for most or a lot
of market participants and new market
participants uh it's really just kind of
uh incumbents how much are they
controlling what are they doing and so
we're seeing that accumulation happen
again and rightfully so with bitcoin
kind of down 50 from the all-time highs
maybe not now i think we're actually
like 40 30 off the bottom uh so
quite a good bounce but uh it's good to
see that those whales that traditional
smart money crowd step in big at 30 low
30k range okay and now this next chart i
think is one of the most important ones
in all of bitcoin which is the
correlation between the nasdaq and
bitcoin and obviously given all the feds
uh interest rate comments and kind of
the anticipation of them raising
interest rates uh bitcoin's been treated
up until the beginning of february as a
risk asset there's been a heavy heavy
correlation between uh bitcoin and the
nasdaq but it seems to decoupled now
what does this mean and what are you
seeing here
yeah so that rolling four-week
correlation at 600 672 hour here this is
nasdaq futures and bitcoin uh got as
high as like 0.94 right now it's at 0.89
but if you're just looking at the chart
bitcoin has a you know quite a big pop
uh you know one of the days was up i
think 10
uh when when that short squeeze happened
and the nasdaq was flattered i think a
little bit down in the day so
quite a quite a decent decoupling i
don't think i think we're not you know
out of the woods yet in terms of the
heavy correlation between bitcoin and
nasdaq or bitcoin and risk on assets i
mean really the reality is everything's
kind of a function of of the liquidity
you know liquidity tied whether that's
go like pulling in or pulling out um and
so
i think really what you're seeing here
is bitcoin often decouples or bottoms
first
or even like uh forms a top first rate
if you're thinking about what happened
in november because of kind of the the
free market nature of bitcoin and also
the derivative market it's the wild wild
west but that's the beauty of it so
bitcoin bottoms bitcoin decouples
because there's these derivative
dislocations that uh you know resolve in
big volatility moves to the upside or
downside and so recently everyone got
over bearish macro sellers i think
basically it looked like they sold all
their coins or for the most part they
just they didn't have any more coins to
sell and those crypto natives those
bitcoin natives stepped in and happily
accumulated and and a short squeeze
ensued and so that's why we saw that
recent decoupling and so you know we're
going to monitor this relationship over
the coming weeks over the coming months
quarters years
but i think it's it's a pretty positive
sign to see that that pop
and kind of decoupling from the nasdaq
and i can tell you one thing is that
every risk manager works for salt is
looking at that relationship between
those two yeah completely agree and i
think that it's a very good uh positive
development and one to keep paying
attention to uh we've got a chart of the
treasury yields and uh everything seems
to be ticking up a little bit what uh
what do you see in here
yeah so this is bond yields across the
u.s treasury curve um you know we've
been talking about bond market a lot uh
and and really you know inflation coming
in at seven percent the entire curve is
still in real terms deeply negative um
but interestingly enough you see the
short end of that curve really bending
upwards and this is before the fed has
psyched whatsoever so powell said all
right we're gonna hike but really the
market is telling him he's gotta hike or
he's you know they're almost like you
know moving his hand without him
actually doing anything the curve is
is telling the fed what it's going to do
and i think this has a couple different
implications there's one yields and the
principal value of of bonds or
really debt securities is an inverse
relationship so as yields go up the
principal value of these these debt
securities go down and so especially on
the on the long duration part of the
curve these these 10 year 20 or 30 year
bonds
as as the the yields are ticking up
they're getting killed in principle
value and i have a tlt chart it's a long
dated treasury uh bond etf later in the
slide deck uh but but really the chart
looks really really ugly not only in the
treasury mark but but across all debt
and credit markets and so uh this
basically we can kind of see that
there's some pain being felt in these in
these asset markets um and you know
everyone likes to look at equity markets
myself included but really credit
markets uh tell a big picture
and what it's saying is that inflation
as well as i think the thing that's not
very understood uh is kind of that
solvency risk uh it's it's starting to
pick up a little bit and we're i think
we're seeing somewhat of a downturn in
the credit cycle and so it's gonna be
really interesting to see uh how it all
plays out going forward all right next
we've got the u.s oil price and uh
it's going up baby i remember at one
point we got like uh what was it the um
uh futures in oil went negative uh in in
2020 which is a pretty wild uh situation
that uh i wrote quite a bit about at the
time but this is the actual oil price
was like the spot oil price if you will
uh and it continues to tick up why is
this important
yeah so uh i mean i'm no expert in uh in
oil futures or these markets but what i
can say is that kind of paradoxically as
oil takes higher
despite it you know thinking maybe it's
inflationary it's actually rather
deflationary over over a kind of a
medium term because a higher oil price
really impacts corporate margins as well
as consumer spending um oil not only oil
gasoline but really everything that's a
byproduct of oil which is like almost
everything we touch and use in
day-to-day life uh as this takes up
really it it's felt across the board for
consumers for retail for corporate
margins and so uh if we see 100 oil 150
oil i've seen some pretty crazy price
targets uh it's going to get kind of
crazy and i think uh it's not good for
a lot of things in the broader economy
uh you know low oil prices is is better
for for the economy that's for sure and
so you know there's gonna be a lot of
pain points here if oil continues to rip
and i think it's something that everyone
should uh you know have on their trading
viewer on their on their dashboard yeah
i think that's a great way to look at it
and then now we've got high-yield bond
etf uh jnk what's going on here
yeah so talking a lot about credit
markets uh you know it's not everyone's
favorite topic here but it's something
it's something to to really watch um you
know it's it's under the surface right
everybody likes to look at equity
indices bitcoin uh and i think over the
long term bitcoin is kind of
not isolated from all of these things
but it has its own monetization process
but over the short term when you see
things like junk bonds the high yield
credit markets corporate bond market is
really rolling over uh it's a sign that
something in the in the broader economy
isn't too health and so this is really
telling a picture here that's
the credit worthiness of a lot of
these borrowers and really what what
creditors are demanding in terms of
yields because as these prices fall in
these bond markets yields are going up
and the reality is creditors don't want
to lend to junk borrowers at four five
six percent right because inflation is
seven percent so before any default risk
you are
are negative real yields and so so it's
basically a guarantee to lose money and
i think what people are starting to
realize is inflation's not transitory
why would i ever lend money at five
percent when inflation seven or
inflation is whatever the reading is
this this next uh you know this next
thursday and so uh it's a really
interesting dynamic that's occurring
here and i think uh if we see
junk bonds if we see these corporate
bonds really start to sell off in a big
way there's gonna be liquidity and
solvency problems across the the broader
economy uh and i think that's something
that despite the you know the recent
bounce inequities despite the the vix
coming down uh from from a tie like 38
over uh about two weeks ago i don't
think we're out of the woods yet and i
think it's going to be one of the bigger
stories of 2022.
and then lastly let's talk on the
20-year treasury etf what uh what do you
see here with tlt
yeah so this is just that when we were
looking at the government bond yields
this is just the principal value this is
actually like the real value of those
notes so uh if you're just looking how
far it's down from the 2020 high even
from the
from the 2021 high
there's a lot of pain being felt here
there's a lot there's tens of trillions
of dollars uh well in in there's 30
trillion dollars in government debt not
all of that's 20 year long dated but uh
basically that the the value of every
asset in the world is based on
on the value of
of these debt markets and so uh when
there's pain being felt here uh you know
there's knock-off effects and equities
and even bitcoin to an extent as is
basically uh you know a function of what
these markets are saying what that cost
of capital is based off of in these
markets and so if inflation continues to
be persistently seven eight even ten
percent if we if we start to get you
know kind of crazy with these inflation
prints uh there's gonna be a lot of pain
felt in these debt markets equities are
gonna have a very hard time doing well
and i think over the short term if there
are any kind of you know macro
allocators i know there are you know
people in the crypto bitcoin uh kind of
world that don't even care about any of
this and are just stacking regardless uh
but there are there are kind of broader
effects on balance sheets and
and the broader macroeconomic landscape
when debt markets are are saying these
these things um and so all these things
are rolling over and i think uh you know
it might be uh you know an opportunity
for buying opportunity uh coming up
completely agree joe john what questions
you got dylan i just want to know what
the vibe is like down there in austin
what are people saying at the conference
what are you guys talking about
yeah i mean a lot of big mining
companies here uh riot i mean just
across the board a lot of publicly
traded miners so having really cool
conversations i can't lie a lot of it
goes over my head i feel i mean i'm
learning a ton but uh i mean it's it's
exciting there's a bunch of different
kind of like innovative things i don't
even know are happening immersion mining
all this stuff uh i mean it feels like
we're really on the cutting edge here
and the i guess the the vibe is that
despite it you know everybody feeling
like you know we're 12 13 years into
this it's still really really early and
a lot of oil and gas guys are here and
they're kind of they're kind of blown
away with with what they're seeing from
the mining side of things um so it gives
me a lot of hope that you know
uh despite it feel like you know we're
we're really deep into this it's still
really really early for for most people
in the world and that's uh you know
that's obviously there's opportunity
there that's a good sign
dylan how do you
excuse me dylan how do you view kind of
the macro sense of things we were
comparing
crypto adoption to the internet adoption
earlier in the show uh what are your
thoughts around like that chart that's
gone viral
yeah i think i mean it's pretty good
comparison um i think it's you know in
terms of like users uh every user in
bitcoin or crypto isn't uh you know
isn't comparable to say you know the
internet or you know maybe like a
telepho telephone adoption cell phone
adoption because you know one user's
capital isn't equal to another
but in terms of broader adoption
bitcoin's not even a trillion dollar
asset
obviously passed that threshold earlier
but there's you know a few hundred
trillion dollars of monetary energy uh
as some people like to say out there and
so uh bitcoin's continuing to monetize
it's continuing to just serve as a black
hole for
uh for for capital uh and i think that
we're still probably in the second or
third inning maybe maybe even not even
that far so uh very exciting and
obviously got a long way to go but we're
just starting to see uh things i've
heard some rumors actually of some some
uh some pensions and some some other big
allocators over the past couple weeks
here uh starting to dip their toes so
we've been talking about it but i think
it's coming to fruition now uh and
that's obviously very exciting glad to
have a guy like you on the road for
bitcoin
dylan last question for you is uh how
much of the conversation there at the
mining conference is about price versus
hash rate or some of the underlying
fundamentals and lead times of hardware
et cetera
yeah i mean obviously prices it matters
but the reality is i think anybody that
has a decent source of power and a lot
of these are like contract negotiated
they're really really deep in the money
um the margins for a lot of these
publicly traded miners are like are
actually extremely wide
um and so you know price even when it
goes to 30k like it's nothing but a
thing for these miners i think the the
real thing that's kind of shocking is
that a lot of these lead times for stuff
like generators for asics for rackspace
uh it's it's it's crazy you know backed
up for for almost you know a year maybe
two out
i i heard that a couple publicly traded
miners have like
you know three four five six ex a hash
worth of miners so like two to three
percent of the entire network's hash
rate currently just on pallets
so would that mean you know they have
the a6 they've already bought them but
they just don't have a place to plug
them in and so you know everybody's
scrambling to build out infrastructure
to plug these things in um and it takes
time and so you know obviously there's
there's a you know that's going to come
and that's going to be built out but you
know there's a there's a lot of people
working really hard on this and
especially in north america so uh it's
it's exciting for 2022 and beyond to see
what you know what comes of that
yeah that that um it's very interesting
to kind of see that miners you know to
some degree they're so in the money that
uh price move is you know it's not that
they don't matter but they're just so
much less susceptible to them whether
it's thirty five thousand forty three
thousand sixty thousand you know it's
just all bitcoin to them at that point
um and uh and if they can hold it
obviously that's uh that's pretty
beneficial um and it feels like that's
where a lot of them have have ended up
now right
yeah did you see what happened uh with
the texas grid like last week yeah
exactly
explain explain real quick what happened
with uh with the miners in texas
yeah so riot negotiated uh with the
texas greater ercot to basically uh you
know buy power at at a fixed price uh
but uh when there's kind of these you
know times of excess demand from the
grid riot agreed to sell that power back
to the grid at a actually a pretty high
price because because that demand is so
high and so a riot makes a lot of money
mining bitcoin but when that texas grid
is really really stressed they happily
shut off their machines and they sell
that power back to the grid at actually
a higher price than what they would get
mining bitcoin so they win the texas
energy grid wins uh the people that
actually need the power wins uh because
they're mining bitcoin creates excess
you know demand for bitcoin or for
energy when when no one else is using it
um so overall you see like people like
the texas governor championing bitcoin
mining as something that builds out a
more robust grid so uh this is something
that's you know still very like not well
understood in mainstream circles but
it's increasingly become you know more
of the mainstream conversation and it's
really really encouraging to see that
happen because just a couple years ago
it would have been you know unbelievable
and now it's just nothing but a thing
yeah it's uh uh
completely contrary to the public
narrative of like mining is bad all of a
sudden people in those geographies
they're very happy that miners are there
right like they're they're they're uh uh
thankful to some degree and uh that
doesn't mean that there's not more work
to do not more improvements to make but
definitely uh not the public narrative i
think that uh that elizabeth warren is
in disbelief yeah
she along with many people uh which is
uh which is pretty comical to me but hey
they'll all figure it out eventually my
friend as you already know all right
let's do a quick follower check how are
we looking on uh on followers for you
where where are we at
across the 120.
500k by the end of the year
you think you think he's got laughing i
don't think it's i don't think it's uh
can i give you a uh can i give you a
suggestion
on
on the twitter game i think that you
should get rid of your current profile
picture and we should just like
screenshot you just like this and then
you put that as your as your twitter
profile
screen grab it you are the only you are
the only person that has successfully
conducted an interview on this uh on
this show with their sunglasses on the
entire time which i respect
gotta be at first all right buddy
appreciate you we'll talk next tuesday
cheers guys thanks later